how's it going brother and you're
welcome - where's the next ride is with
prototype codes why don't you make these
videos anymore don't you care about your
fans I know you're wearing female
underwear on Fridays oh yeah
well did you know I'm wearing a bra - hi
sorry hey welcome to Friday with parrot
back it's been a while haven't it
hesitant English oh really though I have
been making primary feedback type of
videos I just haven't really cold them
right over back I'll show you some
examples but then it also made me think
back what really is Friday's we paid
buying and it's really just me
acknowledging you Bruce in a way or
making a video that engages you bros my
point is I'm all making the videos I do
I love reading in the comments that they
make you laugh and then they bring up
your day that's very cool
but I feel like if I just make those
videos all the time I just become kind
of like a blank wall I'll become
television again and I don't ever want
to do that and I don't ever want to lose
the connection with you bros I do want
to try and reply to more comments I
always read the comments I just never
make a commitment to actually reply to
him
so that's a pledge I make and I also
want to make sure that forever it back
stays a weekly thing
and thirdly I want Fridays Fridays with
codify will come out on a Friday just
kidding that's stupid why would I make
it on the Frog I want to try and keep
this it with you thing uh no matter what
it is cuz I'm very happy where I am
right now
in my current situation and a big part
of that goes into that I just love
making videos now
it gives me so much joy and that
wouldn't be possible if you bro stay and
watch them so for that I am truly
thankful and I want to I want to give
back every week for that I feel like it
I could say thank you and I could just
say oh I really do appreciate it but I
won't actually do something to show that
I appreciate her as well and and I feel
like that should be proud of repair too
bad so if you do have suggestions on
ways that I can engage with you bros
feel free to leave them and I would love
to take your advice for it because I'm I
want to keep it up about that path back
to the top spin around in Zen don't
unsubscribe please thank you guys for
watching
Thank You buzz ring bros and not house
you can be host
I'm not shaming you you dirty dirty
[ __ ] we're 34 million bros right now so
thank you all for being surprised me
bros i that bull i'm butt-kissing way
too much am I feel I feel dirty I feel
like I have to not taking my shirt off
in another video if you want more of
that that's my second channel right here
on this Chinese mines face you do
exactly just the porn channel my belly
is rumbling so I'm gonna have some lunch
and I'll see you in the next video as
always it comes to brofist
Vinny I thought it was another one in
there with this and that's why I put it
with you Oh weapons good bill oh my god
come on I think you keep doing stuff